bindi Irwin said I do to her longtime
love Chandler Powell back in March and
in the middle of a global pandemic it
was even filmed for an animal planet
special
I spoke to bindi and Chandler for their
first interview as newlyweds and these
two are already back to work
you might kiss abroad
[Music]
how are you newlyweds really well are
you taking Chandler's last name that's a
really good question
I kept in deep hours I think that for me
personally you know after after dad
passed away is really important to me to
go close to that this is their biggest
overriding feeling was that Steve wasn't
there and we wished so much that he
could have been there because he would
have been so proud I know you feel like
bindi you were tearing up when you were
saying your vows to Chandler what was
hitting you in that moment everything
just comes at you like a freight train
just before we walk down the aisle I
feel like I'm gonna faint well I
couldn't do that because we were filming
if you watch me it's hilarious because
Chandler did you have any rowdy animal
wedding guests it's gotta be Forrest the
newlyweds have remained at the Australia
Zoo since their wedding and it will all
be featured in an upcoming Animal Planet
special on June 27th okay Robert
honeymoon you call it a honey Xun
[Music]